porque cree usted que boris está tomando
esta decisión y que costos puede
conllevarle especialmente entre quienes
apostaban no su programa inicial de
gobierno
de parte agradeciendo nuevamente la
invitación que me ha sido formulada y
claramente este es un problema político
y un problema de seguridad de estado que
está enfrentando el presidente boris
porque dentro de su campaña presidencial
el planteada entre otras cosas y
potenciar el diálogo con aquellas
comunidades de aquellos grupos que
estaban buscando estas reivindicaciones
territoriales y también lo que se llama
ahora de sí militarización de las zonas
específicamente la zona que incluye la
araucanía y las zonas aledañas y por lo
tanto adoptar una decisión como ésta a
la cual él también durante cuando en el
gobierno anterior se adoptó o se adoptó
este este estado de emergencia se opuso
férreamente genera ruido entre sus
partidarios que al mismo tiempo era una
exigencia de muchas personas porque
efectivamente el problema de asegurar la
araucanía es un problema real es un
problema inventado y también hay que
dejar en claro que no es un problema que
te pertenece o queriendo saberlo
únicamente este gobierno desde el
retorno de la democracia es que este
problema no se o no se ha podido
solucionar o resolver adecuadamente
bueno precisamente no ha vinculado a
esto último que sí este conflicto entre
el estado chileno y el pueblo mapuche
lleva décadas no podrá ser quizás boris
quien finalmente lo destrabe o lo
resuelva
al menos las intenciones las tiene el
presidente cuando menciona que no
únicamente va a ocupar la represión como
mecanismo de solución a este conflicto
sino que también potenciar el diálogo y
cuando la ministra del interior señala a
petición del mismo presidente la vocera
de gobierno también lo hace que se va a
conversar y dialogar con aquellas
personas que emplean mecanismos
violentos ya hay una solución pero hay
también una paradoja un contrasentido
porque estamos ustedes saben muy bien en
un proceso de cambio constitucional y
justamente el estado de excepción quiere
que todo el presidente boris eso en esta
acepción que no se encuentra contemplado
en el nuevo texto constitucional por lo
tanto ahí hay también críticas respecto
de qué tipo de constitución quiere o si
efectivamente está apoyando las
modificaciones en materia de seguridad
que se están planteando en el proyecto o
en el borrador de nueva constitución
siempre nos queda poco tiempo pero
precisamente quiero preguntarle acerca
de esto no la convención constitucional
de chile redactora nueva constitución de
crear país no como una nación
plurinacional algo histórico para los
reclamos de los pueblos originarios
esto podría llevarnos a pensar que
podría haber más posibilidades de
destrabar el conflicto
o ganar más posibilidades pero también
plantea un desafío
porque los especialistas en la materia
yo me dedico al derecho no me dedico a
la historia de la antropología pero los
especialistas en la materia señalan que
un gran problema que se ha planteado en
el tratamiento de este conflicto entre
el helado de chile y el pueblo mapuche
es entender que el pueblo mapuche es
unitario es único la no tiene la xunta
tiene una única un único interés
entonces parte de esta plurinacionalidad
del estado también tiene que
incorporarse dentro del diálogo con
estos distintos sectores que conforman a
quienes están en conflicto con el estado